excuses we can talk to the president of
moderna stephen hoge great to talk to
you today
and congratulations on yesterday's news
uh how many
vaccines do you hope you're going to be
able to get out in the short term
in the very near term by the end of this
year we hope to be able to supply 20
million
doses and that now includes
approximately 5 million that will be
providing to the uk
by march or starting in march of next
year
in terms of the uk's access to these
vaccines
is it true that britain initially chose
not to buy them back in may when
when other countries did we've had a
long-standing conversation with the uk
government and so
actually we've continued this
conversation since early may
um we were pleased to announce uh
yesterday with the uk government that
they did purchase up to five million
doses this time
and and perhaps more over time um those
have been conversations going on since
may and i can't comment on whether or
not they
refused or didn't didn't purchase um
ultimately they did
is it fair to say though that the actual
clincher the the making the decision and
the uh
getting the numbers and the figures
didn't actually have until after your
announcement yesterday
it certainly accelerated it um over the
past couple of weeks as we completed
enrollment of phase three
um we actually accelerated those
conversations with the uk government
quite substantially
the clincher certainly was knowing the
vaccine is effective at preventing
covert 19.
but it's important to note that those
really have been constructive
conversations over the last
many months and the reason why we were
able to execute agreement so quickly
yesterday was because of those
constructive dialogue over that time
so yes so it was uh discussed and agreed
after lunchtime
um why is it so expensive compared
to for example the visa vaccine you
think the fires vaccine is going to be
able to be
produced sold for around four dollars
yours it's thought about 25
is that a right ballpark figure that's
ball buck park correct we haven't
disclosed the
agreements with every other governments
but directionally correct
our technology is based on the new
messenger rna technology that we've been
working on over the last decade
there's been a lot of work to scale that
up over the last year
and enable manufacturing which is a
substantial amount of investment and so
hopefully even at 25 given the um
the impact uh both economic and social
and medical impact of covert 19
it's a quite modest health intervention
compared to many of the other things
that that people are doing right now
including testing which often costs much
more
great concern about covert obviously for
those at high risk for medical reasons
and also the elderly
i talked to an immunologist yesterday
and they said that that was their real
concern
uh wanting more information from
yourselves and all of the other vaccine
companies
how how much of your vaccine was tested
on those groups and how confident are
you that they can really benefit
we're very confident based on the data
and so if you look at our phase three
trial we included
up to 25 percent of people over the age
of 65
and we included another 17 of people who
were under the age of 65
who had co-morbidities like diabetes
or obesity that put them in very high
risk of severe covalent 19 disease
and so actually over 40 percent of the
30
000 participants in the trial um had
high risk of severe covet 19 disease
that's particularly good news because if
you look at the efficacy we saw
which was 94.5 percent against any covet
19.
um that held up across all of those
groups and in particular
um there were 15 cases over the age of
65
uh in in the study who had uh who had
covered 19
and similarly there was a 94 plus
percent reduction in in that population
as well so
overall although it's preliminary
analysis we're looking at
clear evidence that the vaccine can
protect those at highest risk of
of severe disease the last thing i
wanted to say is that
we did also look at severe covenanting
disease and this is disease that leads
to for instance hospitalization and an
icu
or respiratory failure and the vaccine
was 100 percent
effective at preventing severe
carbohydrate so the combination of those
two facts
um provides us great confidence we hope
great confidence to immunologists and
physicians
that the vaccine will protect those at
greatest risk in this pandemic
and i suppose the other big question is
how long do you think that the vaccine
once
it's been administered will actually
allow the patient to be protected from
covid
you're i believe are still carrying out
tests into that when do you think you'll
be able to say
yes it's um it's an ongoing thing uh
so far there's no evidence of waning
immunity on the vaccine but it's
important to note that we really only
have about two months
of follow-up in these trials we will
continue to follow these subjects for up
to two years
and so all 30 000 participants will be
followed up to two years even if the
placebo participants eventually receive
the vaccine
and we'll be updating on a regular basis
uh to regulatory authorities and public
health officials around the globe
our hope is that given the the magnitude
of the efficacy we saw
uh early on here a hundred percent
against severe disease and 94.5
percent against general coving um that
alters well
that this is going to be a substantial
immune response and long
long-lived protection usually when you
see those sorts of numbers it's
think of the measles vaccines or other
things that we've received
that provide us many years of immunity
now that's we need data to prove that
um i'm quite optimistic that we're
looking at least a year but hopefully
much longer
ultimately only time will tell well
indeed and in terms of storage
much has been made of the fact that your
vaccine needs to doesn't need to be
stored
at such incredibly low temperatures as
other vaccines that that are being
developed how how important is that and
do you think you can
actually get that temperature even even
warmer
isn't that the hope yes we would love to
actually make it as easy as possible to
distribute in all healthcare settings
including uh in you know perhaps the
developing
world um for now what we're proud of is
that the
um the storage conditions and
distribution conditions are actually
pretty standard refrigeration and
freezers and so stored at minus 20 c the
vaccine is stable we already know for
six months
possibly longer we only have data right
now to support six months
and that can include up to 30 days in
just a refrigerator two to eight c
which really means that given we can
ship very small quantities and you can
store this in a refrigerator that'll
exist at many gps offices
throughout the uk or or in local
pharmacies
that you'll be able to distribute the
vaccine into those areas of greatest
need
and not just into central places that
have high-end infrastructure for storing
it at all to cool temperatures
we hope over time to extend that but
ultimately the data we have today
supports
um this sort of distribution and of
course
for countries like the uk and america
relatively temperate climates
um it's not such a massive issue is it
but in really hot countries this is an
enormous issue how how widely
distributed do you think your vaccine
would be able to be in those parts of
the world
uh so at this point we we hope because
refrigeration is
is relatively common for drugs and
vaccines um that it could be distributed
much more broadly
but it's important to note that there's
still work to do we
only have uh you know six months in
frozen conditions in 30 days in a
refrigerator
you would really love to be able to
distribute refrigerated or possibly even
room temperature
for the hardest to reach parts of the
globe and so we have work to do others
have work to do and and this is why
we're going to need multiple different
vaccines to succeed it's important to
note that you know pfizer and modern are
the first through
the gates here with with clear fxc data
from phase three trials
but we need others we need the
astrazeneca oxford vaccine we need uh
jensen's vaccine
um it's going to take multiple multiple
jobs to succeed in stopping this
pandemic globally
uh and just a final thought obviously a
lot of different people go in to help
fund
these developments don't they is it true
that dolly parton helped fund
your vaccine uh
i i don't i don't know i don't think so
um we've we've received support from
many though and so i'd have to go
confirm that
um i don't know myself vanderbilt
university medical center i'd
i'd read but we certainly i won't run
with that you're one of our partners
certainly that's that's possible and
very likely so yes her
support through vanderbilt we did we did
work with vanderbilt in the in the early
research the vaccine and we did
uh work with them even the conduct of
the clinical trials so yes of course
that's
that's true through that support